hey guys it's justine and today i'm
getting a chance to do something that i
wanted to do for a very long time and
that is visit the apple fitness plus
studio i am absolutely just so excited
because i have been such a huge fan of
apple fitness plus and if you guys
aren't familiar with what that is it's a
companion fitness app that goes with
your apple watch so you're able to do a
ton of different workouts from hit dance
meditation they have yoga they even have
specialized classes that they just
launched not too long ago for things
like getting ready for ski season and
they also even have on the apple watch
time to walk time to run where you have
guided walks guided runs outdoor and
it's just a really cool experience and
since it's launched i was so blown away
with the production value the trainers
that they have are all incredible every
single class that i've ever taken on
fitness plus i never felt like i had my
time wasted and i have tried a lot of
fitness apps and i've tried a lot of
fitness accessories and as someone who
has taken all of these fitness classes
what i was so
just blown away with with apple fitness
is how thoughtful the classes were
developed and it didn't really seem like
that was intentional until i actually
visited the studio and realized how much
goes into just producing one of those
episodes like this studio is state of
the art they have over 27 trainers
currently they have like 13 cameras and
they have this one big fitness studio
and the way that they have the camera
set up is it's like this robotic system
they have a grid of lights the cameras
are controlled from a control room they
have those also mounted in the ceiling
and they have some on the ground as well
the way that this studio is set up is
you don't really need that many people
in the actual studio just the trainers
that actually getting a chance to go
there at the studio and see how much
preparation actually goes into one
episode like they're all shot live but
to get to that point there's so much
that goes into it behind the scenes hi
i'm jay blahnik welcome to the fitness
plus studio in santa monica i'm the vice
president of fitness technologies for
apple i can't believe i'm here right now
we are so excited to have you it's
really amazing that we've finally been
able to bring in some special guests and
we are thrilled that you are one of the
very first i mean this has been
something i think that i wanted to do
since like the first class that i ever
took i was like what are you guys doing
here this is so incredible and the fact
that you're in santa monica and it's so
beautiful and it's just it honestly is a
dream come true i'm really glad you were
able to make it today so what's it been
like for you kind of seeing this all
evolve has it been like a year and a
half yeah it's been a little longer than
a year and a half we launched in
december 2020 and you know we launched
with incredible workouts across a
variety of workout disciplines and a
beginner program to get started but we
have been innovating month after month
during that year and a half time frame
to just try to bring as many experiences
as we can to users we know that
different things motivate different
people so we came up with a great audio
walking program with time to walk and
then we've offered guided meditation we
added pilates we've got a new program
called time to run really just leaning
into the idea that fitness plus is a
service to welcome everyone no matter
where they are on their fitness journey
and they can do it anywhere anytime so
as an episode is being shot with a
specific trainer they're also working on
the one for the next week and that's
something that's great is there is new
content every week on apple fitness plus
and because they're turning out this
high quality 4k content like there has
to be an incredible workflow and getting
to just sort of be there and experience
it and get a chance to talk to the
trainers and see the process in action
was really really cool hi i'm jessica
and welcome to the fitness plus studio
in la i am so excited to be here it's
just
so incredible like what you guys have
created and what has this been like for
you kind of just seeing through the
process and creating these classes and
helping so many people around the world
well thank you for coming here it's
amazing so my favorite part of the
process um
is probably the rehearsal that's where
the real collaboration happens so we get
assigned our workouts we create them and
then the final step between
that and coming on set is being able to
rehearse with your teammates where you
start to bounce ideas and really dial
into the detail the trainers all kind of
work together on this specific episode
and they run them by several different
people to make sure that the actual
workout that they're doing flows that it
works with different body types and it's
just a comprehensive workout all
together that's what i love is i feel
like you can always come back there's
new content and you guys are continuing
to evolve this too with like the time to
walk i was so excited about the time to
run too because i was like is there
going to be some running classes outside
what what can we expect i think that's
what's so fun is you're kind of
surprising us with all of these new
little goodies well we've had a really
great time innovating and um we're just
going to keep pushing you know we we
really committed to this notion of
trying to welcome as many people as
possible regardless of where they're at
in their fitness journey so it'll keep
coming and in the classes they always
have other trainers from different
disciplines so you might have people in
dance or hit kind of taking a tread
workout and it's really fun because
those will be modifications so most of
the time you can find one of the
trainers to follow that fits your
fitness needs so is there anything that
you could give for anyone who has never
kind of used this before or if they've
never started working out like what's
your best piece of advice my best piece
of advice is just know that we all start
as beginners so come as you are and
there really is something for everyone
whether you start with a five minute
mindful cool down and that's how you
enter your workout and you build up from
there so every every workout counts
every moment counts and um
yeah our real aim is just to help you
live a better
better day but to really be able to go
there to the studio and actually kind of
see it all happen was really awesome and
i being a huge you know editing and tech
nerd to see the studio it was absolutely
beautiful from the ground up everything
was so just immaculate as you would
expect from apple and it's so cool
because the way that this studio was lit
everything was lit perfectly no matter
what set you were shooting on and just
being in the studio like you guys it's
it's mind-blowing and i've been in a lot
of studios over the years in los angeles
and this is like i've never experienced
something like this it's a pretty
amazing place we took inspiration from
our retail store some of our really
amazing retail stores around the world
you know one of the things we always
notice is if you look in it's not
uncommon to see an eight-year-old next
to an eight-year-old and we thought
that's the same kind of inspiration we
want for this studio a place that
everyone will want to work out in a
place that feels inviting and welcoming
but of course to be able to release the
amount of content that we release every
week across so many different workout
disciplines guided meditation or audio
programs it needed to be state of the
art for us to be able to put out that
much content each week so there are
things here in the studio that you
wouldn't see anywhere else in the world
and we're pretty excited about the way
it's all come together it's amazing and
i feel like you guys launched at such a
perfect time where people weren't able
to go out well the way that everything
just works with the apple watch it's all
so thoughtful and i think even just
visiting you guys here it's even more
thoughtful than i ever thought oh that's
amazing we love to hear that you know we
obviously been working on fitness plus
well before the pandemic but we were
really thrilled that it was able to come
out at a time when maybe people needed
it the most and now that people are sort
of getting back to a slightly more
normal life we're also really thrilled
that it's designed to be able to use
anywhere anytime and the trainers really
are incredible they do feel like you're
you're best friends and you've got a
chance to meet a lot of them today and
you know some of them and i think one
thing that's really clear when you meet
them is they are exactly who they seem
to be in the service they're they're
really inspired by the idea of helping
people get fit no matter where they are
starting and it's just awesome
unfortunately i couldn't film a lot in
the studio but i did get to see how
everything works basically from start to
finish and it was very fascinating to
just see this production up and running
and while we were there they were
actually filming a live workout so i'm
excited to see that work out in a later
launch down the road when that one
actually comes out i'm gonna be like um
i was there i saw that happen i also
love that throughout a lot of these
workouts they do use asl and this was
also very fascinating they actually have
the trainers take asl classes every
friday so that they're able to further
improve their sign language when they're
incorporating those into their workouts
and i thought that was such a great idea
and i've been very fascinated by
asl and i've kind of actually wanted to
take it myself so i think i'm just gonna
start going down to the studio and be
like hi guys uh justine here i'm here
for um the trainers asl classes i'd like
to uh do we get report cards i'm not
sure hey what's up i'm coach bakari
thank you so much for joining me here
like this is honestly a dream come true
being here and like meeting you guys who
i see all the time like on my ipad when
i'm working out so what is it like for
you to know that like you've been
impacting so many people around the
world i would say that that is that's
the best part um and that's but that's
also the inspiration and it's why we do
it it's why we hustle it's why we take
time with the workouts because the goal
is to bring our best work and energy
here and to give it and share it with
the world i mean i'm honestly speechless
walking in here like it is a dream come
true so what's that like kind of being
in this space and just really
experiencing like the state of the art
the most high-tech fitness classes in
the world to be honest it just it makes
you feel really good and it definitely
makes it really special like everything
from
the garden in the background to the ring
wall when we're doing hit and things
like that so i think it just has its own
special energy and it we do feel like
everything is top class because we're
here to do our best work and again to
just give that to other people i can't
actually believe right now what's
happening i'm inside of the apple
fitness plus studio and i have taken so
many of their classes and it feels so
strange to actually be here because this
was something that i wanted to do for so
long and the fact that i'm actually here
inside of the studio it is by far the
most incredible thing that i have ever
seen like the lighting the cameras it is
so
just uh i'm speechless thank you guys so
much for watching i had the best time
getting a chance to check out this
studio it is by far the most incredible
thing that i have ever seen so i look
forward to taking some more classes
and yeah that's it i'll see you guys in
the next one bye
[Music]